- What's up Believe Nation.
My name is Evan, my one word is believe,
and I believe in people more than
they believe in themselves,
and my sincere hope is
that if you see in yourself
what I see in you, you'll be
able to change the planet.
And so to help you on your journey,
I started the Best of Tony
series as an experiment,
as a test. Tony Robbins
has had an impact on me,
and a lot of the viewers on my channel,
and so I thought maybe once a month,
maybe bring some of his best
content that I really enjoyed
to inspire, enlighten, motivate you.
And so today we're going to
learn from Tony about how
he turned somebody who
had a lifelong stutter
that really held him back in
life and he turned it around
and transformed the man's life as well.
I hope you enjoy.
- My name is Rechaud Bell.
I've stuttered for as
long as I can remember.
My freshman year of college,
one of the first courses I took
was a speech class and I froze.
The grade I received was an F.
I went from a full time
college student on scholarship
to stocking shelves on the
graveyard shift at minimum wage.
The industry I'm in is
basically a sales industry,
and stuttering has gotten in
the way of closing a deal,
or even to schedule an appointment.
I could have a more successful
career if I spoke fluently.
- Tony it would mean so much to me
if you could help
Rechaud with his stutter.
He is such an incredible man,
and I know there is so much
more potential that he has.
Everyday is a struggle for him.
His stutter holds him back a lot,
and makes him question himself.
It's so hard, because I
can't do anything about it.
Tony, if you could help,
that would just mean so much
to me and to our family.
- Rechaud, nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you too.
- Well, tell me a little
bit, if you would,
about what's going on in your life.
I understand you're having
difficulty in terms of
a speech impediment or stuttering.
- I just know, and my life I rejected it.
I was ashamed of it.
I drew back and was extremely
introverted, but accepted.
- You've gone through several stages
that are perfect stages.
You've gone through ashamed,
you've gone through rejection,
and you've gone through acceptance.
You've accepted this experience.
Now that you've accepted
it, you can eliminate it.
- Yeah. Sign me up for that right now.
- Okay, now I want you to
notice what you just said.
Do that exactly like you said.
Yeah, sign me up for that right now.
Say that again.
- Yeah. Sign me up for that right now.
- Now you just spoke perfectly.
Now there were other parts of your speech
that were perfect as well,
but you just demonstrated
what I'm going to show you.
It's hard as human beings to figure out
what makes people do what they do.
But because I spent 30
years in a 100 countries,
with more than three and
a half million people,
at this point I could be an
idiot and I'd have to see
there's patterns that make people crazy,
that make people happy,
that make them fulfilled,
that make them stutter.
Once you know what the pattern
is, it's so easy to change.
Almost every unconscious
pattern happened a long time ago
when we make a decision about something.
We model something.
We model a behavior or
we reject a behavior.
Deep in our unconscious
it becomes a pattern
to avoid pain or to gain pleasure.
When did you start stuttering?
Tell me the moment.
What's your earliest memory?
What's your earliest memory in life?
Take a moment.
Your earliest memory in life.
- Probably two years
old, get up on a Saturday
watching cartoons and eating cereal.
I believe it was Rocky and Bullwinkle.
- And Bullwinkle, does he have a stutter?
R-r-r-rocky?
- Wow.
- And that's your earliest memory.
And when Bullwinkle
got himself in trouble,
how did he get out of
trouble when somebody was
going to like torture him
or do something bad to him?
- He would scream out,
'R-r-r-rocky,' right?
- And he always stuttered when he said it.
So I want you to do this,
all patterns like that
happen because you've
forgotten something
right before that moment.
And now you're locked in by the pattern.
There's the decision you made
or something you experienced,
or life was very different
right before that moment.
Go back to right before that moment,
and I want you to
recapture what you forgot.
- My parents were probably arguing.
That was happening quite often.
- Yes.
- Like to the point where
my dad got physical.
- And you didn't know what to do, did ya?
- Needed clarity and assurance.
- Yeah. And did you get it?
- I guess I got that
from, 'Hey, R-r-r-rocky.'
- Because the one thing
Rocky always responded to was
- Help.
- But not just a cry for help,
a stuttering cry for help.
Even a child who can't
consciously understand that
he feels helpless will
find a way to intervene
and stop pain going
between those he loves.
And one of the ways to do
that is create a new problem.
So you found a way to protect your mother,
stop your father from
beating her, and it worked.
That was perfect for a two year old.
Not good for a 30 year old Rechaud.
- Right.
- So now what? Do we stay two?
- No. No we don't stay
two. We don't stay two.
- You're a man, you're 30 years old.
You've lived life. You've been
through all kinds of stuff.
There's a warrior in you Rechaud.
Feel him and where he is.
Breathe him in.
The warrior is one that can face anything
and storm through it.
Warrior, once he sets his mind to it,
he will do whatever battle is necessary,
for his wife, for his family, for himself.
Make the sound of the warrior,
the first sound that comes to you.
Make the sound, make the
sound of the warrior.
- (screams)
- The warrior does not stutter. Ever.
Own the warrior.
- (screams)
- Tell me what the warrior says. Now.
- The warrior says I am free.
- The warrior says ...
- The warrior says, I am brilliant.
- That's right. The warrior says ...
- The warrior says that I am electric.
- The warrior says ...
- I am awesome.
- Ask the warrior, do I
need to stutter anymore?
- No.
That was awesome.
- You're awesome.
- Thank you, Thank you. Wow.
So, what's next coach?
(laughter)
(audience applause and whistling)
- Give him a hand. Rechaud,
ladies and gentlemen.
Rechaud. Give it up for Rechaud.
- Oooooh, yes.
Just a quick question.
Would you just share, Rechaud.
What was going on before,
and what had changed for you?
- Tony, it's just been locked
up inside of me forever.
I've had a speech impediment,
I've stuttered my entire life.
Guys, 30 years of stuttering, stammering,
but that was a condition that I chose.
I chose to stay there.
I chose to identify as a stutterer.
That's why I was afraid of greatness.
I was afraid of my light shining.
But, no more. Because
today, I am the voice.
Today, I am the warrior.
Today, lives will be changed.
Today, I saw this moment as a child.
I knew that I would be on stage talking
to countless of thousands of people.
Thank you for the pain.
Thank you for the obstacles.
Because that brought me
here today to talk to you,
to give you my story, to give you me.
Now you got me, I got you, and do it.
(audience applause)
- Thank you guys so much for
watching. I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know have
you seen this video yet?
If not, did you like it?
If you've seen it already,
did you like it too?
Let me know your comments,
leave it down there below.
I'm really curious to find out.
This is also an experimental series,
this Best of Tony series on this channel,
so if you want it to
continue, let me know.
Leave it below, share the video up.
If this series has the
impact that I'm looking for,
then we'll continue.
If not, we'll find something else.
Your viewership makes a big difference
in the deciding factor here.
So thank you guys for watching,
I hope you enjoyed it.
I believe in you. I hope you continue
to believe in yourself, and
whatever your one word is.
Much love. I'll see you soon.